هذا هو الإرهاب التاريخي لغرب العراق الحرام الذي
يختبئ فيه من الصعب
السيطرة على التضاريس
والمناطق النائية دون وجود أمني دائم
، وفي هذه الأراضي ، بمجرد حلول الليل ،
تهاجم عصابات داعش
وتقتل وتنهب مع الإفلات من العقاب ،
نتجه إلى موقع
هجوم داعش المروع الأخير في
غضون دقائق من الانحراف عن الطريق الرئيسي
وعلى طريق ترابي ،
وصلنا إلى ما هو أكثر قليلاً من
مجموعة من المنازل
الطينية.لم يأت الموت قط إلى قرية يوسف هاواي البالغة من العمر 72 عامًا
، وبهذه الطريقة
لا تزال هناك بقع دماء على  قُتل
شقيق يوسف الأكبر وخمسة
أقارب آخرين
في جوف الليل قبل أيام فقط كانت
تقوم بالتنظيف
أو تحاول على الأقل
[موسيقى]
هذه هي الطريقة التي عثروا بها على إحدى
جثث النساء وما قيل لنا
هو
أنه تم اصطحابها إلى
هنا منطقة الاستحمام
وهذا هو المكان الذي قاموا فيه بإعدامها للتو على
الرغم من إعلان هزيمة
داعش لم يمت
، فهو يكمن في الظلال في
انتظار الأرض  ستسمح له
بالارتفاع مرة أخرى
، قامت قوات الأمن العراقية باعتقال
عشرات الآلاف من أعضاء داعش المتهمين
[موسيقى]
في بغداد ، نلتقي بهؤلاء الرجال الأربعة الذين
حُكم عليهم بالإعدام بالفعل
واعترفوا بأنهم جزء من
شبكة إرهابية.
مقاتلين ، أحدهم ممرضة والآخر
نقل مفجرين انتحاريين
مثل جميع المقاتلين الأسرى الذين
تحدثنا إليهم على مر السنين
، يقولون أيضًا إن الانضمام إلى داعش كان خطأ ،
لكن هذه هي الطريقة التي يبرر بها أحدهم
الشعور بالتعرض للإساءة من قبل
حكومة الدرع والرغبة في ذلك.  كان الانتقام
وسيظل أمرًا محوريًا لقدرة
داعش على إغواء الناس في
صفوفه عندما نسأل عما إذا كانوا لا يزالون
يؤمنون بأيديولوجيته ،
فإن السؤال يقابل بشكل ينذر بالسوء
بصمت الرجال غير المستعدين
لإدانة التفكير الملتوي
الذي أعطاهم على الفور كما رأينا في هذه
صور
مثل هذه القوة المسكرة ، والغرض
من الشعور بالسيطرة على
حياتهم وحياة الآخرين
في مبنى مجاور هو قاعة المحكمة
التي  لا يريد أولئك الذين ينتظرون المحاكمة في هذا اليوم
الظهور أمام الكاميرا ،
لكن قضاياهم هي أمثلة كلاسيكية
لمظالم السكان السنة ،
فهناك ستة رجال هنا يواجهون
تهماً بالإرهاب ،
نصفهم يقولون إن التهم الموجهة
إليهم ذات دوافع سياسية
تعود إلى  2011. النصف
الآخر ليسوا متأكدين تمامًا مما
يُتهمون به ، لكنهم جميعًا يقولون
إنهم أُجبروا على الاعتراف
تحت التعذيب.
لطالما انتقدت منظمات حقوق الإنسان
العراق بسبب ثقافة
التعذيب المتفشي
والمحاكمات المعيبة ، لكن القاضي عبد السطار
يقول باريكتار إن
العراق يلتزم بالمعايير الدولية
ويلتزم بقوانين مكافحة الإرهاب الخاصة به ،
والمسألة هي أن أولئك الذين وقعوا في مأزق
هم أولئك الضحايا الأبرياء
لديناميكيات الاستقطاب التاريخية في العراق التي
تؤلب سكانها السنة والشيعة
ضد بعضهم البعض ،
إنها ديناميكية يتم تضخيمها  في
مخيمات اللاجئين المترامية الأطراف لأولئك الذين
فروا من القتال
ولكنهم ما زالوا غير قادرين على العودة إلى ديارهم
هم أولئك الذين فروا من القتال  o كانوا منتمين إلى داعش
أو يشتبه في انتمائهم إليه
، يخشون الانتقام
في خيمة واحدة ، التقينا بآباء ثلاثة
رجال تم اعتقالهم ثم
اختفوا
في النظام القضائي
العراقي الغامض ، تقول والدتهم شامب
إنها لم ترها أو تسمع عنها  أبنائها
منذ أن تم التقاطهم
قبل ثلاث سنوات
لأنها تتحدث عن معاناتها التي أصبحت
ساحقة
فهي لا تعرف مكانهم أو ما إذا
كانوا على قيد الحياة حتى
نلتقي بأحد أطفال ابنها المحتجز
لا تريد والدتهم
الظهور أمام
الكاميرا الأطفال  يواجهون مشاكل أنهم
يتعرضون للمضايقات من قبل أطفال آخرين
يعرفون أن والدهم ليس هنا
ويخبرونهم يا والد
والدك هو والدك هو
والدتهم تقول لهم إنها كذبة لكنها
لا تزال تلطخ حياتهم الصغيرة
وتدينهم  لحياة من العزلة والرفض ،
ليست حياتهم سوى قصة واحدة مثال واحد
لما يعتقد الكثير من السكان السنة
أنه جزء من حملة انتقامية من قبل
الحكومة التي يقودها الشيعة.
يمكن لداعش أن
يفترس هذه المشاعر التي يتردد صداها في
جميع أنحاء هذه المعسكرات المعدمة
بأحلامها الشبيهة بالسجن التي
تتبع في
الغبار ، والشعور باليأس
الضعيف بشكل خاص هو
أطفال أولئك الذين اختفى آباؤهم أعمام آباؤهم
أبرياء أو مذنبون قتلوا
أو احتجزوا
مدير المنطقة صلاح  يقول حسن إن
الحكومة لا تستطيع أن تتخلى عن
الأجيال الشابة
من الكراهية التي
تغرس في داخلهم مشاعر معقدة أخرى
يمكن لداعش التلاعب بها بسهولة ،
وهناك القليل الذي تم القيام به
لإعادة بناء الأنقاض التي
خلفتها حرب العراق على تنظيم الدولة عاطفياً أو جسدياً
وما إلى ذلك.  حتى الآن ، لم
تبدد الحكومة العوامل التي
سمحت لداعش بظهور
الشعور بالتخلي عن
العقاب الدائم
للاستهداف التعسفي ما لم يغير
ذلك ، يبدو أن التجسد التالي للإرهابيين
مقدّر له
أن يطارد هذا البلد مرة أخرى
أروى دامون سيينا الموصل أنتم جميعًا.